já viu
[Música]
anysio
tudo depende do sim
o meu pai causou na época em cheio a
seca tem a galera que acha que me canais
que o be é mico esther e aliviar o
stress de pilotar uma extensão de mais
então vim passar uma semana aqui no
azulay que o irã o instagram do atleta
aparece na tela la aqui é sensacional o
meu também está aparecendo na tela lilac
também é sensacional tem fotos
sensacionais aqui você quer de campo
grande mato grosso do sul tem show em
dia 21 em garanhuns dia 22 em recife
teve três de caruaru os ingressos vão
para o show não estou no méxico agora
[Música]
porque agora eu tirar férias de meses na
zona tirando de pouquinho em pouquinho
da aliviada no estresse é porque tava
demais e um estresse muito fácil para
qualquer besteira fica estressado até
aqui eu consegui me interessa fazer bem
estava aqui a gente tomar banho que iria
enxugar não tinha toalha e chamou cada
toalha o amor que é natural a moto
estava na sua casa do tarzan pra quem é
que os pilotos como é que as pessoas das
casas das ocas usava a toalha pra cá é
natural rapaz tem que andar por aqui mas
a moça não tá certo que o tempo no
território do amor pelo amor de deus não
entendeu que isso aqui é natural a
tranca da porta é um peixe a gente tem
que tomar banho ficar no xiii as pessoas
passando nos noivos há sete anos nós
estamos nós é natural a moça quina hoje
no último dia eu fui fazer a dancinha
bem e atuária
eu não sabia disso tomar 15 banho e vou
jogar com essa história eu me estresso
fácil deixar com que com data de
validade de alimento e rentável e
augusto neto olha a data de validade dia
13 de outubro que coincidentemente é o
dia que vou fazer show no rio de janeiro
no engenhão não é propaganda
coincidência aí hoje é dia 15 de outubro
ficará e passou do dia era a mãe que eu
como site cheiro não tá cheio de azeite
azeitona
a união está bom há sempre uma pessoa lá
perguntar é barra ba itaqui dia a dia 3
mas hoje é dia 15 será que alguma coisa
podia sim um filho dá uma margem de
segurança o cara bota dia 3 mas no dia 3
caiu em cena pode ser dia 18 e 21
mulheres e leu a 8 da primeira
enquanto o bota na boca em plenário
nesta ano o primeiro pq tudo vai do
pescara e vou morrer certeza eu vou
morrer certeza hoje é pecado hyogo tica
outra com que o game está é muito eficaz
e internet eu vim pra cá quem não tem
internet em vários lugares mas eu
preciso é que os oligarcas som eu tenho
um nome já o inter sondou não tem
internet o twitter só pode quando fixa
internet mas que o voto dos anos 80 e eu
nem estava lá só pra começo de conversa
foi eu sou enderson é muito ruim que ela
já dormiu na casa de um amigo meu que o
pai de noite desligava e de noite da
meia-noite de jong e desliga a vida pra
que o efeito nem geladeira mas não
desliga a medir liga já destinou
desgarrado nervosa mesmo não tem que
ficar até um ano e quando a gente não
tem 3g não tem 4gb banda larga é que
fala é quando a gente mais precisa ter
que ps toda hora é preciso que o taxista
é eu não confio táxi que não usa gps que
ele sabe assumir ele pensa a cidade que
dirige 1980 é a mesma de hoje não é só
pegar por aí vai da esquerda na na rua
verdura do rush não chegou a falar em
tom e pega a direita com a parede eo
pensar besteira precisa pesquisar em
toda hora tem hora que eu tô aqui do
nada eu penso em sair e vômito com
pesquisar entre aqui passarem vomita
essa curiosa nunca vi um passarinho 3g e
4g
a banda larga ainda é só o canal falando
é só passar envolvimento eu não sei é
uma questão filosófica que só pessoas de
áudio rio pode responder à pressão de
alto nível como assim como pelado por
épo aristóteles 7 para instalar legal
então vamos lá falar com ele vários
estados já morreu há instantes morreu é
faz tempo já 1985 por aí fiquei triste
agora uma espécie muito eu vou comprar
remédio que acontecerá em comprar o
remédio se não tem receita é o remédio a
rússia vai comprar famoso eu quero
entrar com a treta de plantar agora
falei ml 1 miligrama eu digo que sei lá
o que é o iml com isso o pessoal
trabalha no iml agora saber o que a oms
não sei o que é o ml que a unidade
medida agora não sei quanto cml é o
suficiente chuta m l miligrama falei
'leva m é o de 250 ml ou dcml é de que
eu sei lá meu amigo eu respondo o máximo
que não mata e cura ao caráter receita
de até a receita pronta agora vai ficar
mais fácil entrega
receita pra ele ele né e pega receitas e
olha o médico parece que era o pai do
bebê bonito escrevesse a dengue é do
comitê
você olha fala cá e o que língua maia é
essa daqui e um figo [ __ ] não consigo
entender aí o cara da farmácia pega e
olha fala para dentro de potássio 250ml
três vezes ao dia como é que ficava
conseguiu nem cigarro outra coisa que um
estresse muito gente que chega na hora
certa é eu sei que não é legal chegar
atrasado não vi mas na hora certa também
tomar com o negócio a oito horas só que
7 58 assim a 7 55 da mensagem era você
o tac não acredito que já chegou a um
programa de culinária eu me estresso
demais consigo assistir eu sei que tem
muita gente funds de coisas de pessoas
mas eu não consigo cara porque eu não
gosto que ele faz receita que tem os
ingredientes que a gente não tem na casa
da gente e nunca vai ter porque eu
também vou comprar porque eu vou comprar
essa merda no outro dia ela já tem outra
receita como fazer negócio em si não
primeiramente você vai precisar de
cogumelo do sol um saldo himalaia no seu
dia do cenipa que lado é o himalaia
saúde eu sei que assiste na ponta com
uma lembrancinha para lá não sabe
ninguém saber da digibase cônjuge ou
nome fei ge bretão eu acho endereço mais
bonito e gengibre ou não fosse gengibre
eu num eu não falava com ninguém pena de
ganso roda quem vive na amazônia se
cogitado para o delta do rio sagrado
carnes piano de gui muniz ao alto beleza
vamos fazer do armário teme o juiz a zon
net faz soprar dessa receita e eu só
tenho o samu é que faz só com o sal o o
negócio tem como que não tem nada que
faz só com sal o próprio sal é um monte
de outras coisas que você não tinha em
casa e nem digo você criar saúde
possível com bolacha água e sal da água
com o sal já no com sal já na fábula
chuva eu adoro chuva o som da chuva é
sensacional
a chuva ela rega a terra nascem plantas
cultivos larga também alaga mata mata
mas a culpa eu tenho raiva do pingo de
chuva que cai das telhas da casa é
aquele que eu tenho raiva porque tá show
biz canta pouco se fala nem dá pra
molhar não tá tranquilo aí você vai
entrar dentro de casa e uns pingos que
cai da casa que parece que é um quilo aí
tu vai um do fmi é já parece que cada
gol que caiu na desgraça de até um quilo
de água que eu tenho raiva é simples
cara é um milésimo de segundo que isso
acontece mas isso me estressa tanto fico
então o que é que eu vou passar perfume
o buraco do perfume popular errado sabe
o que a gente fala assim o [ __ ] quando
o buraco perto da virada o teu dedo ou
cará escorre pela moto fica assim é uma
raiva quando isso acontece pode falar
assim
rose não burocratizar a enviar por
telefone assim a acaray kg labor day
quando troca as palavras num dia desses
eu chamei um táxi chega a multa diz
assim cheguei por chopin e pega agora
vou pegar de 8 a 15 e chegou no
historial de lei não amor eu sempre vou
porque acho meu caso de amor eu senti
que ele ficou meio assim a sensação foi
aquela bem vocês sabem ficar de férias
muito tempo e vai pra escola de novo uma
professora de mãe a cabeça da gente
pensa professora deixou do banheiro é a
boca fala a mãe deixem no banheiro todo
mundo a professora alice conversa aí
vocês realmente são como filhos para mim
em jogo hoje a maioria do jogo que tu
quiser agora é para baixar é um instante
do bota que peito já joga já se não
gostou já paga já baixa é outro caso a
internet 3g e wifi volta dos anos 80 na
eu lembro que quando eu não tinha
internet a jogar um jogo da argola que
era o revólver rendeu lhe o jogo que
tinha duas as tinham aqui uma kit azar
bolinha era com água etá apertava assim
jogava a jogar bolinha pra cima eu
apertava vinha 4 argola e encaixava
direto na arte e aí ficava uma árvore do
lado de fora fala vou botar é essa aqui
fazer o jogo apertava sair às quatro
fiquei triste agora eu queria saber de
você o que é que estressa você o que
você odeia o cometa aqui embaixo do
espécie que gostei escreve no canal para
não perder nenhum vídeo e tamo junto é
nóis
valeu ebr e porque pepe pt caneta no
chat chuva e poeira